well friend of mine is retiring early
and they asked me
what's the best deal out there that
there is on a gpu
and
that spawned a conversation beyond just
that
but uh let's take a look at what happens
when i'm spending someone else's money i
mean i actually wasn't going to make a
video
but i had a lot of fun living
vicariously through
through their wonder so i'll share what
we did because it was kind of a lot of
fun
[Music]
okay so the budget the budget is the big
question right because you know what do
you want to spend well he said he'd
already been looking at
you know two thousand dollar gpus like
the 30 90 you know 30 90 ti and
uh you know we sort of joked when did
graphics cards get so expensive i mean
in the old days with like the voodoo 2
it wasn't really super expensive so yeah
we sort of joked about that when you see
a five thousand dollar gaming computer
though it really does soften you up to
the idea of a two thousand dollar gaming
computer which in a lot of cases is
eighty seven percent as good as the five
thousand dollar gaming computer so
you know you gotta find like what's the
reasonable deal
okay okay so you're shopping for
something high-end but are you saying
that's what i asked so
and he's also planning to do contract
jobs on the side and that kind of thing
so he's gonna have other income it's not
like this has to last 30 years or 40
years or 50 years depending on how long
he's planning to live and you know it's
like there's time now there's finally
time there's an aspect of that where you
just want to get something really good
and i ask okay well what about your
other stuff you know your monitor what
do you got for a monitor he's like oh
i've got a 4k monitor don't worry about
that
but uh the lulls on that was yet to come
remember that okay what are you gonna
play look if you're gonna play old games
you can use an old gpu and then when you
run out of old games then you can buy
whatever gpu is current where in an age
where generation on generation we see
gains that
are pretty significant from card to card
and
okay well there's a gotcha with that but
we'll come back to that i mean crypto
madness aside 500 spent tomorrow on a
graphics card is almost certainly better
than 500 spent today and on the long
enough time scale that's universally
true it just makes sense to do that like
i say cryptocurrency
is making that really true now where
that was less true a little while ago
and we're in an age when gpus are hot
and player three intel maybe is entering
the game so what did i pick
i picked the asrock formula
6950xt at around 1100 right now this is
still
pretty much the only high-end option
because the other high-end options are
selling over msrp
and so we bought it the 6950 xt is a
modest bump in performance over the 6900
xd and because i was so happy with the
6900xt that's why we went with the 6950.
remember this
i reviewed this from
asrock this one not from asrock
and since the 6900 xt launched i've been
using it and the driver improvements
alone have added more than 10
performance to most games ray tracing
has improved everything is better it's
great and
i get it i get where amd is going i mean
a bad software experience can ruin what
is otherwise top shelf hardware and amd
has done more to improve their software
in the last 12 months and i'm not just
talking about like the baseline driver
stuff i'm talking about their tech for
upscaling and visual fidelity and
improvements that gamers everywhere can
experience but they're doing a lot of
leg work for the game developers as well
but you know what else is about to ruin
our day
the old
006x55c
that's a 4k 30 hertz monitor from dell
4k 30 hertz you didn't even know that
was a problem until it was a problem i
mean it was one of the most expensive
high-end 4k monitors that ever existed
for 4k and it's got a razor sharp
picture and blah blah blah but uh yeah
no
this ain't happening only 30 hertz is a
horror show
so
yeah he's gonna use the money that he
saved on his gpu to get this
this is a gigabyte f32u or i'm sorry
m32u
this is a 32 inch 4k monitor and this
makes sense
this makes sense for 4k gaming
4k 144hz ips crystal clear display this
is why the 6950x
makes sense this is what it was designed
for and i started i started the fun with
quake 2 ray tracing this is pretty much
the first game to get vulcan ray tracing
support on amd and why
because it's the same software
philosophy it's open developers can
implement it quake 2 is so old the
engine is basically open source and the
difference between
you know quake and
quake 2 and something else
well i mean just look at this look at
the wonder of this
playing this game with just
better software is a transformative
visual experience
it is so good with dynamic lighting
that it's it's a wondrous experience
especially if you've played the older
version we also took a look at the
odyssey g9 neo as maybe another monitor
and he really liked the 5k resolution a
lot and of course the oc formula handled
it like a champ yeah it's really inside
your brain when you're playing because
all you see is monitor
but with the firmware issues and the
other bugs and not every game is going
to support this just absolutely
completely absurd widescreen resolution
we ultimately decided against the g9 neo
so
you know of course
of course our plucky little system with
the 6950 is doing an amazing job you can
hear it in the background
it's pushing the pixels at many many fps
easily 160 fps i've got the vsync cap on
this thing set for 160 instead of 240
because i'm a crazy person but yeah
works great
samsung is also exiting the display
business
and we also found all the bugs in the
firmware from the other stuff that we
did so we ultimately noped out on that
monitor i mean it is a nice monitor and
once you you know plug it into your
brain because that's what it feels like
when you use your monitor is that you're
just you know putting on jordy's visor
from star trek and then you're there oh
we also consider the lg 43-inch oled 120
hertz that's hdmi only though which is
why it sucks and the hdmi spec the
people are responsible for hdmi 2.1 is
not an open spec now i still use lg
you know my lg oled monitor with
megadesk and of course the azroc formula
is no slouch on that system either i
mean it's a big big card it's got big
big card energy which is
what you need
but this
this was just right
great color accuracy ips and i have to
say it was a lot of fun
living vicariously experiencing someone
else's wonder playing all these games at
over 100 fps but also on a good display
if we side by side
quake 2 with doom eternal
i mean they're related they're cousins
you might not know this but quake 2 was
designed for gaming at a resolution of
320 by 240 30 fps but if you had a crazy
five-breathing machine you could maybe
run it at a resolution of 640 by 480.
but not long after quake 2 launched it
did support even higher resolutions
1024x768
it's magical fast forward to today
now we regularly game at 4k and even
beyond i mean the 8k gaming demos aren't
that far behind us playing games like
horizon zero dawn i'm constantly
surprised at how photo realistic things
in that game
are and more modern games in the unreal
engine if we speak about just
texture resolution and frame rate and
pixel fill rate and that sort of thing
i'm not sure that it's possible for us
to go
as far with visual fidelity as we've
already come in the future
i mean think about that for a second
how far we've got to go
is closer than how far we've already
come
when you're looking at all 12 polygons
in a model a 3d model in an older game
like quake 2 or even low poly lara croft
and tomb raider it'll never be as much
of a visual fidelity leap
from where we are today
as it was from where we were then with
whatever's coming in the future i mean
ray tracing look at ray tracing that's
the first evidence of that ray tracing
is simulating light we're doing that
basically in real time now which is a
fundamentally different approach than
we've done in the past and we've used
that as a yardstick to measure the
performance difference with different
video cards different vendors the
lighting in quake 2 it had to be baked
into the textures
because that's just the only way until
recently but that's what i mean when we
look at the future or try to imagine
what the future is going to be like
we're basically already there with
photorealistic games even shadow of the
tomb raider that's kind of an old game
if we look at that
compared with horizon zero dawn the
character models the level of detail
it's a pretty big difference in horizon
zero dawn there's a lot more visual
fidelity in that than shadow of the tomb
raider but it's a lot harder to
immediately notice that level of
fidelity now adding new technologies
like ray tracing and other probably you
know physics was added to games physics
acceleration and now we don't really
even hear about it it will be like that
with ray tracing it'll probably be like
that with other gaming technologies but
that's what i mean when i say that we've
probably already come farther in terms
of visual fidelity than
until we get to holodeck level
technology the the fruit is not going to
be quite as low hanging when you break
that down in terms of video card
specification we're talking about pixel
fill rate and
frame rates per second shaders
rasterizers we'll talk about variable
rate shading where you can shave a few
milliseconds off of a render and all of
this sort of plays into
software upscaling we're not really
rendering
4k worth of pixels anymore we're not
really rendering 8k worth of pixels
anymore certainly with ray tracing we're
not ray tracing that full scene we're
only retracing a select little bit of it
and then we're using software to upscale
that and fill in the details the next
generation of card and the next next
next generation of card are only going
to improve on these themes
it is not
a dramatic improvement in terms of just
the raw pixel fill rate and i can prove
it if you look at 1080p gaming for this
latest generation of cards everybody i
think would agree that the last few
generations of video cards from the
major players in the market have been
head and shoulders improvements over
prior generation products dramatic
improvements breathtaking improvements
but we look at the 1080p frame rate
gaming and the performance improvement
is not as pronounced as 1440p as as
pronounced as 4k
and the reason for that is because the
bottlenecks exist elsewhere there's
things there's
things in the game engine things to do
with the texture fill rate things that
have to do with memory bandwidth when
you're pushing to 300 fps but also the
visual fidelity like what you as a gamer
experience moving from 30 to 60 fps is
night and day moving from 60 fps to 120
fps that's pretty big that's another
doubling
uh and you can definitely feel that
moving from 120 fps to 240 fps
you're going to notice that a lot more
on the display technology side than you
are on the gpu side
the gpu
stuff required to do that is going to
have more to do with upscaling than it
is
actually filling the pixels in a
traditional rasterized pipeline kind of
a way
that's why the software is so important
and that's why having an open platform i
think is going to be critically
important
for the future of gaming if you don't
want to be locked into just one choice
i mean this is running at 1080p at 174
fps with obs running in the background
when you look at the little details in
horizon zero dawn the foliage the
shadows
everything that's going on in the
background the particle effects
the
water effects
the different things in the game there's
different engine
parts that are handling this
physics
ray tracing ray tracing's just the new
hotness right now you don't hear
anything about physics acceleration but
it's there remember when hair works was
a thing and it was added to game engines
and if it didn't have hair works then it
wouldn't run well
we've got better than hair works now
done a different way
that's universally available depending
on what the game is
i mean games are the point where the
actors that are doing the voice stuff
it's motion capture and they're
reproducing the muscles of their face
digitally and rendering that in real
time depending on whatever your hardware
is there was a time these would be
pre-rendered cut scenes and uh it would
take weeks to render them on
supercomputers and then which would play
back the movie
that's not really the case anymore
well it depends on the game but
in this case
so for the highest end gaming the
fastest card in the market there's
really only one choice and it didn't
cost two thousand dollars this is the
one that i picked and i really like how
far we've come in general
sets gaming on you know quake 2 and that
sort of thing oh and the 6900 and the
6950 they can also do rock m for machine
learning mark and i are working on a
guide for that on the level 1 forums but
that's a that's a video for another day
in fact the rest of the build and all
the other details that go into this
maybe as a video for another day but uh
i just wanted to share because you know
seeing quake 2 ray traced i know that's
old news that's from 2020 that's like
two years but going from that to
everything else and sort of
re-experiencing some of your old
favorites or even just your favorites
from last year with a
monster gpu upgrade kind of is a lot of
fun so if you've got you know a
five-year-old gpu now might be the time
and
with the
scalpers pricing basically gone
yeah i know there's a new generation of
gpus coming at some point in the next
six to eight months
maybe sooner maybe farther we don't know
but uh
yeah i just i don't know it's crazy how
far we've come from the olden days and
it should be plain to see that the
increase in visual fidelity
over the next couple of years is not
going to rival what we have already seen
it's going to be changes in the
technology you know ray tracing and ray
tracing 2.0 is going to be the new hot
thing not
pushing pixels and that i think is
something interesting not a lot of
people are talking about and in the time
since i put this video together amd's
offering a deal to sweeten the pot
they're giving away up to three free
games be sure to check that out there's
a link to that below but uh yeah if you
pick up a brand new graphics card from
amd
you might get one of three or up to
three triple a games depending on which
model you get now the less expensive
models you don't get three games but
check that out it's pretty awesome i'm
one of those level one if you want to
discuss we can hang out on the level one
forums chat
screenshots fun stuff all right i'm
signing out and i'll see you there
you